b
hello
you guys should be able to hear me fine
hopefully
hopefully you guys can hear me fine do i
look
okay do i look okay i hope i do
i should be fine man we should be good
to go
curious if you guys can hear me man give
me a mic check put it put in there if
you can hear me do i sound good do i
sound fine
kind of look blurry a little bit
hopefully that fixes stuff a little bit
i always feel like
youtube
makes stuff like look really
convenient i don't know
all right so let me go ahead and
get this stuff taken care of man we
about to have we about to struggle
about to be a little bit of a struggle
bus
but i think i i think we got it man i
don't know exactly what i'm gonna go
with i was looking uh yesterday when the
game launched i did look a little bit on
exactly what options we have
as far as
how we can actually go about this game
and what we can actually use
but besides that you know that's there's
not a lot of other stuff i've looked at
besides that
now why
i don't like how it's so hard
they change stuff all the time
i thought there used to be like a chat
feature in here
looks like they changed it so i mean
do i sound fine because i thought i was
sounding a little bit
not what's what i'm looking for like i
felt like
the game was over shooting me talking if
that makes sense
so i did feel like that i don't know if
it sounds like that now but it did feel
like that was the case a little bit ago
so we're gonna you know maybe i need to
change the settings
on the actual camera i don't know i
don't know you guys tell me how that
feels man tell me how that feels
let me go on here since i
go and uh share this out man share this
out to as many people as you guys want
to
you know this is gonna be a struggle
we're gonna struggle together i don't
know what i want to pick i'm gonna be
real with you i don't know what i want
to pick they i feel like they gave me
too many options they gave me too many
options like
there's a lot i don't i don't like being
a mage in these type of games because i
feel like it's cheap i felt like being a
major chief maybe a healing ability
you know i like the prisoner
so they come with shields
i don't know what do you guys think what
looks good on here what do you guys
think looks good we got we got the the
hero
he don't i don't what's that what makes
him a hero they need to be a little more
specific on what makes these people
unique stats you got a warrior here
so it looks like some of them are a
little bit higher levels than others i
was kind of thinking about the samurai
you know the samurai looks like maybe my
flavor
[Music]
how can your play through streams have
perfect audio and attic show be uneven
sometimes
because i don't have to maintain other
people's
other people in in the show because
sometimes their their audios be going up
and down sometimes like that's something
i can't control but i can control it in
the streams if that makes sense
[Music]
i don't even know what this profits
about like why
what makes them a profit that they have
that wooden stuff around their throat
that looks really weird
i don't really want to be a bandit you
know warrior seems pretty solid
but i feel like everyone will pick the
warrior man let's pick the samurai i
feel like the samurai
is is that person man i think we could
do something with the samurai
let's call it addicts
all right we good we good young a
we'll go with that let's let's make him
a mature person
a medallion invite with crimson what's
this be playing on the xbox
series x that's what i'm playing it on
man the xbox series x a goat of shining
an eyes people between i don't know none
of these do
swords breaking through uh the m statues
that can only be used once okay fire
sacred branches charged with the
eliminating power said to origin from
the the demigod i don't know what that's
about five pieces of broden pawn boost
physical damage
negation
oh that's what's up man
i'm dying involved with crimson
increases let's do that let's do that
all right so let's stick with
the samurai
we're gonna be the samurai chat
we gonna kill it with this samurai
probably get killed a bunch of times but
we gonna try to kill it with the samurai
i chose to say i kind of like
i have some i have a lot of experience
when it comes to these type of games but
not like the greatest experience if that
makes sense
i need to be a little bit more choosing
on what i play with this kind of stuff
uh let me fix this again you guys know
how it is people be coming on and off
let's put do not disturb
tell a story
the fallen leaves tell a story
they always have that weird like
that really good sound uh golden
incorrect or uh is cracked early game
was shot
you can always actually really
appreciate the fact that from software
continues to make original content and
they don't really do too much besides
like dark souls one two and three they
really do unique stuff like checkered
demon souls
and now eldon ring so it's really unique
to see a studio constantly making new
experiences and hitting it out the park
in america the eternal
is nowhere to be found
queen miracle the eternal is that like a
goddess and in the night of the black
knives
godwin the golden
game run steadier vrr i don't even know
what the vrr thing is man i'm gonna play
the game man i'm gonna just play the
game i don't really try to get too much
into
the type of
features like that because then i feel
like it eventually takes away from my
mindset if it's not in the game i get
weird if it is in the game but that
makes sense
the mad taint of their newfound strength
look how crazy he's reading this is that
a snake in some dude's forehead
some creepy stuff a snake in a dude's
forehead a war from which no lord arose
that's a nice picture right there man
that's how i want my dude to look
oh maybe not fight him but i want my
dude to look like that
that dude looks like something off
deadly seven deadly sins it's an anime i
like
it's over now oh
rise now
he tarnished
you tarnished
doing a really good job narrating that
lost grace
speaks to us all
so is he is he saying from me to
[Music]
oh no
that's pretty graphic
got his sword straight through his
abdomen
[Music]
acne
they all
know it
oh
he did a good job narrating that man i'm
gonna have to be real with you he did a
good job narrating that he got me hyped
maybe not as hyped as i could have been
but he got me hyped
and one other
whom grace would again bless
so i assume that is
are we the tarnished is that is that who
we are
dead people getting resurrected you know
they love doing that
i just want to play man let me play
to stand before
the ring
uh i don't know we'll look we'll look uh
valorous we'll look i don't know if
there is but we'll look
i have faith in them man all right so
here we go
all right so can can can i do well i
think i remember dual wielding in the
actual
the beta
hold up
i want a dual wield
i don't want to shoot an arrow i want to
do well
okay
and it's sad is that probably i couldn't
even explain that situation to me
atari's wizard finger
i don't
there's got to be a way to to to grab
that with both hands
there's got to be a way to grab that
with both hands i don't want to
i don't want to shoot a bow very often
or a katana all right all right
that that that's fine we need a cortana
a katana we'll go get a katana
right now we just we're just gonna get
out there man we're gonna get out there
all right
oh
it's nice looking game
they are all
from software games do have that like
unique feel and that unique look
well there's no way to take it off it
just
goes right back
goes right back and on and off man
i mean that looks like a katana don't be
real with you
all right hold up hold
up let's let's figure this out man
i feel like this is a katana
okay
that's definitely what i messed up on
come on
come on hold it
all right so it doesn't let you do it i
don't know
has to be a way to one-hand it i i don't
i don't i don't know how to man
it doesn't look like left hand unarmed
i don't know man i don't know i feel
like there was in the beta i feel like
there was the beta but i don't know
about this
this looks like a boss room
yes i'm playing on the xbox series x i
appreciate you uh answering that
christopher jones
what is going on here
a graphic sign already
i don't like how like
i'm a little bit fast
look at you ah
you got a little bit more range than i
anticipated there my friend
[Music]
you got a shield on your left hand
you got multiple swords
oh
okay you're supposed to die there
gotta hold
the left bumper and press y
gotta hold the left bumper and press y
all right we'll try that we'll try that
left bumper
press y
all right thanks justin i appreciate
that
see
i
another thing that um
another thing that is going to really
hurt me with this game is it's been so
long since i played the dark souls
formula like i'm used to like the more
fast-paced stuff like sakura at this
point
so it's usu it's weird using a shield
because normally i don't like using
shows i like going straight for the kill
so i'm gonna have to get used to using
that shield again and i never played
dark souls 3 either i started it a
couple times but i never actually
finished it
and i've been told
that is a really good game
oh that's the horse they giving me the
horse already don't worry tauren don't
worry toilet fortune is on his side
torrent
we found him here after all
look at that horse the horse looks good
one of his kind is sure to seek
the elden ring what is the elden ring
what is it
i kind of want if it does violate the
golden order i don't even know what the
golden order is either man
you can make it quick if you keep the
weight down yeah i remember the white
system
i remember the white system i feel too
uncomfortable being that that beefy
maybe i shouldn't have picked a samurai
in that case but you know i want to do
that dual wield you know quick kind of
gameplay man i kind of want to play this
like sakura and i know that's not going
to happen
i know
i shouldn't try to play this like
another from software game i really just
enjoyed that from software
shecaro filling man i hope they make
another one of those
i really that that might be the best
from softball game i've ever played
all right so there's your your health
so it's the mana and the in the magic
all right
so i grabbed it with the sword
all right so
let's move along i don't think you can
hold that sword with two hands
i think that's a one-handed sword
hold up
all right so i figured it out how did i
do that
all right all right all right i got it
guys we got it
touch the grave
examine
use the stone crypt
oh i don't have it okay so i guess
that's their way of telling me yo you
you need this to get that cooperative
uh multiplayer you know make not this
stream but you know maybe next stream
i'll be i'm down for some of you jumping
in man i'm down for you some of you
jumping in
oh
oh
i like that that's nice
oh that feels nice man
brave tarnish take the plunger or
learning remembrance recall the arts of
war in your warrior blood
oh you want me to jump off
i felt a little uncomfortable doing that
but we gonna do it
still no precious item okay
that's a little bit of a drop i didn't
feel like doing
but we good we good
a little precious item
the sights of a grace
wrestling outside regards to restore
your hp fp
what does fp stand for i guess that's
your mana or whatever it is and clint
any status it will also refill your your
sacred flask however most of the enemies
you defeated will be revived you can
find sights of grace by going with the
lights coverage so i assume these are
the lanterns
yeah these are the lanterns
uh sakura i like more than ghosts but
ghost is a really good game guys if you
haven't played ghost i really recommend
playing ghost ghost is a really good
game
oh
i don't know if i was supposed to hit
him but we we moving we moving man
oh
you didn't lift through that very well
did you
oh
bad about a swing
yeah
i i definitely uh think that that game
probably would be i played it on the
regular standpoint i don't really play
games on the hardest difficulty it just
dude
i can't do that like
bad for my blood
i have him on stream a few fps uh
equipped and arguments each and can be
equipped with up to three armaments
allowing you to toggle between them
armstrong could be two-handed melee okay
okay i got you i got you
oh what's up man
what's up you gonna try to attack me
yeah there you go
i knew he's gonna try that man
on the road again i like being a sam
right dude the samurai looks pretty
pretty solid
oh
oh got it got to get that
that reach man gotta bring that reach is
that an arrow that's an arrow
just in case
oh but
he's not really that strong
come on come on try to shoot me again
oh he's got a
oh
ah
you hit me a couple times man he hit me
a couple times
all right
i got to get better at fighting the
people with the shields
come on let's go
you me
okay so this one's the shield okay
you me let's go
model a model let's
go oh
hold up
i like that man
pretty
crouching
how do i crouch
can you see me
can you see me
guess he can
they got that from shekero man they got
that from sakura
i got you
i think they were trying to teach me how
to do a backstab there but i already
know how to do a backstab
stance breaking some attacks may break
your energy stance giving you a chance
to perform a critical attack
charge attacks and jump attacks make it
perfectly easy to break an enemy stance
while jumping okay
all right
[Music]
we don't need to do a bunch of damage
man
oh that one two one two one sue
upon down you will revive at the last
side of grace that you visit however if
there is near you died you could choose
to provide there instead
okay that's cool
all right i assume this is going to be a
boss
yeah
oh here we go you guys
probably won't beat him on my first
attempt but i'ma try
you can perform a counter-attack
immediately after blocking the enemy
easy to break into stance immediately
after blocking an attack
all right
oh man
oh you're doing some damage
oh
i didn't know he could move like that
i didn't know he could move like
that kind of did like a little 360 there
for a second just a little bit
where can i go
so that first boss was uh not what i was
expecting i was expecting a little bit
more of a of a fight there
but it's okay man it's okay
it is teaching you the game
that is so i can understand why
it wasn't a little bit harder than i i
would expect
i feel like i have to go fight that dude
again
hold up
get the the bonfire let's get some
health going
yeah you could block
i'm pretty sure you could block
gotta get good at the counter man i'm
hoping the counter run like functions
pretty decent
i'm hoping the counter functions pretty
decent
we'll see though we'll see
oh here we go
it's a nice little area man nice little
area
touch this grace
name is something different obviously
grace exists to guide the taurus and
lead them along the proper path even now
some sites of grace were retained the
power there golden rays will guide you
along the way
so i got to go that way
oh yes oh yeah tarnish
between for the elden ring
of course you have
no shame in it
unfortunately for you
however you are made into this what the
hell is amazing without guidance
without the strength of runes strength
invitation
an invitation
what's the round table hold it
it seems
to die in obscurity
you could give me a little bit more
information the hell is the round table
hold or whatever the hell he's calling
it
and graphics don't look that bad man
like i get it you compare it to like
horizon
or you know
even even to gears
pretty much any exclusive i don't think
these are going to be better clearly
but
i don't play the these type of games for
the graphics and you guys know me i
don't ever really talk about graphics
like that to a point either you got good
gameplay i'm there 100 there it doesn't
matter you got good game play we we
golden
now keep in mind
i don't mind if you guys backseat game i
know a lot of people get upset with that
it doesn't really bother me i'll just
ignore you if i want to
that that stuff doesn't bother me
oh okay i was about to sneak up on you
another grace
fast travel to the graces okay
we gotta go this way
i wonder where my horse is
the exploration i can already tell is
gonna be phenomenal in this game
all right let's go
you me
model model
yeah
get dealt with
i don't know what vrr is you guys don't
have to educate me man educate your boy
educate me man
you guys know i don't know this tech
stuff
guys no i don't know this tech stuff
don't make me look dumb please don't
make me look dumb
i don't know that text up
i'm playing on a cheap monitor too i
mean it's not a cheap monitor but i'm
sure compared to a lot of you guys it's
a cheap monitor
[Music]
variable refresh rate
um no i'm not playing on that but i'm
gonna kill these birds if i can
i got no problem killing birds
free sinking and see i think you have to
have a certain monitor or something to
play those type of features and i don't
have that um unfortunately i got like a
400 monitor which is an expensive
monitor to me but i know some of you man
rocking with thousands of dollars worth
of like one monitor like all my monitors
together probably ain't even 800
and that might be pushing it 800
yeah that might be pushing it to be
honest with you
i don't want to fight all these people
and the
in the beta the demo you could go up
here and there's a grace up here
carl peda how you liking the game so far
so good
we ain't really far into this
but we watch it man we watching
[Music]
lost grace discovered
let's rest at the sight man
because in the beta something happened
here when i rested here
yeah see
i think this is when you get your horse
in the beta but i don't know
if that's how it is in the real game
because you know sometimes they'll like
change the beta stuff for like when the
actual game comes up i don't know if
that's changed in here or not
you need a good monitor i have a
and it cost me 800 and it's a 4k hundred
and twenty vr that's that's what's up
man that's what's up
from beyond the
i am melaner
i notice
i notice frames if it's not 30 now
because i i was on pc so i do notice
that
but when it comes to
like general things i don't notice
if a game is dropping as much unless it
drops like an absurd amount like from 60
to jeez
what happened to her eye
it's gone
i feel bad for her have you heard of the
finger maidens no i haven't are you one
they serve the two fingers
i have two fingers
and aid
to the tarnish
please say you're one
but you
i am afraid what is a maiden our
maidenness
i can play the role of maiden she can
play the royal does that mean she's a
maiden or she turning runes into
strength
to aid you in your search for the elden
ring
in the search for the elden ring you
need only take me with you
i'll take you
[Music]
ah
another matter another matter i bequeath
to you this ring
this is for the horse i think
yeah it's for the horse use it
to try to travel great
i think
it will
i'm not pimping her out man
we here at the iron lords podcast do not
support
prostitution okay
we ain't doing that
you guys are ridiculous pimp her out
shall i turn you'll let my hand rest
upon you
share them with me
all right so let's see here can i can i
level anything up no i'm a broke dude
i'm broke
use the spectrum okay so press the the
left one
[Music]
okay so
all right let me see here
there we go
i like that there we go
now remember correctly
what's up guy
oh
you having issues
oh what happened
i feel like you ha you're not trained to
fight someone on a horse
yeah you probably could see me get
curved stomped i ain't gonna lie just a
little bit not a lot just a little bit
i had to play as samurai
in honor of lord cognito man he'd be
proud right now or is he about the ninja
i can't remember man ninja sam are one
or the other this one's for you carl
what is that
what is that
[Music]
travel back to the church
why is there lightning coming out
what's up
oh there's like dragons and and people
on horses and
man i'm going man i'm going i'm going
back to the church man someone in the
chat said i gotta go go to the church
i don't really know where the church is
but we're gonna try to find it we're
gonna try to find it
that's fine man i'll go back to the
church man i got you firestar i got you
i don't know where the church is but i'm
gonna go try
oh look man
you can't really compare eldon ring
to halo like they're kind of different
games
and if
if they were trying to
then that's that's bad on them they
shouldn't be doing that
oh yeah we ain't fighting him
is this the church that you guys i mean
i don't know if this is a church or not
but we're gonna try
we gonna
try
but you said we can fast travel to it if
it comes down to it
look halo is a great game they just need
they need they need content man they
need content in there i enjoy it and i i
do plan on going back to it eventually
but the game's just been lit here lately
past time memorize spell sort of chess
oh yeah yeah i would say it open
worldwide this game's probably on
another level
then
than them
halo's a good game i just felt like they
could have executed that story open
world a little bit better
who is crying
okay so i have to fast travel all right
we'll do this man we'll do
i don't really like the sounds i'll be
hearing in there either
they're kind of uh terrifying keep in
mind guys
keep in mind
we will
be streaming more of this game on twitch
twitch
slash iop or iron lures podcast
or just look up ironlord's podcast
twitch or
i might put the actual link in the
actual chat i don't know
but right now
this is
this is how i'm gonna start doing okay
chat now listen
i'ma
go ahead
and play the big games one stream on on
the iop channel because that's our
thing with you guys man you guys
come here every day we're going to give
you guys this one stream and then after
that
i'll take the game i'm playing and start
streaming on iop i'm trying to get a
little bit better when it comes to this
streaming stuff it's new it's a full
concept to me gotta gotta gotta gotta
bear with me
i'll get i'll get it i'll get it
eventually but right now
we're playing this
past time
they said that oh okay
is this game harder
than shinobi
you
suspect vanished
may i have a word
sure a pleasure to meet thee tarnish
pleasure to meet you i'm the witch
i'd heard tell of a tarnished hurtling
about atop a spectral steed
and upon looking into the matter
the talk isomize is of thee
thou art possessed to the power no thou
possessed the power
as i had hoped
i was entrusted this for thee one would
think that she would make you
all right so that's the calling bell
that you guys were talking about to the
bell for calling forth spirits okay
we'll call the fourth the spirits that's
fine
when a spirit calling bell you can
summon ashes
okay okay got you man got you forgive my
intrusion tarnished i doubt look at her
face it's awesome
i don't know man hold up we'll look at
her face the lands between
how long will it be i wonder
before the tarnished tire of a basins to
the two fingers
i don't know
you don't have to
yeah let's
oh
oh god
yeah let's
i don't want none of that smoke
that's a lot of smoke man
i wonder if i could beat him if i get on
my horse
hold up let's get on your horse
i don't want to fight him yet
i feel like
fighting him right now would be a
mistake
fighting him would be a mistake right
now
oh got you
done
finished over
now i remember
there was like a cavern or something i
found in the beta that there was a boss
there so i would like to find that so i
can get that experience from that boss
oh
i feel like it was over here somewhere
but when i went over here earlier it was
like a bunch of lightning it kind of
scared me
is his name metal face i didn't check
for his name man
well i mean you hear metal face doom
[Music]
clearly you would rather watch paint dry
if you in my chat talking imma just
point that out there man imma just point
that out there
[Music]
this is dogs yeah
oh
they got a little bit of health
feel like it's down there
now i feel like you could jump as long
as you double jump before you hit the
ground
yeah okay
ow okay maybe i was wrong
all right man you getting a little bit
too much there metal face you're going a
little bit too much there
we don't gotta be with all the uh
all the aggressiveness man
vancouver
replace your test the numbers okay
all right so we're not going that way
yeah that's what i said man you being a
little too much we don't need to go into
all that
like you said you'd rather go watch
paint dry go watch paint dry man
we don't need all that extra stuff in
here
we just trying to play games man we just
trying to play games that's all we
trying to do
is these swords
no
yeah yeah yeah
i'm just gonna keep you in time out
there fam
you don't gotta be all extra man i feel
like you're the one being sensitive not
him
okay
get up
all right
yeah
i'm not trying to get that
yeah give me a second
i'm not on the iop channel hold up
yeah i'm gonna have to give you a ranch
flame
people just being a little bit too extra
for no reason
so i don't understand how people like
enjoy games because they it's like they
come in these chats just to troll not to
enjoy the game that's playing
like if you're gonna come here just to
troll why don't you just play the game
and what is this
oh great
people get me killed looking at this you
played horizon forbidden west yet it
looks better than the game
um
you did a review uh a review on video
yeah i'll be doing a review
eventually
right now i gotta review um destiny
the new expansion
so let me handle that first
and then we'll start handling that
let me go back there
i'm letting the person in the chat was
messing me up a little bit
but i think he's gone now so
he's not gone he can't talk for like
another minute minute and a half i think
you get stopped talking for like a
minute and a half or something like that
yeah fall damage got me pretty quick man
i gotta remember that
one would think that you could like
one would think that you could stop
yourself from falling real quick
with like the second double jump
i don't know yet
i'm not going there though
because i remember it was like a cavern
or something
that we went to
and that's how there was like people
down there at the bottom and it turned
out to be an entire like dungeon like a
little dungeon it was pretty cool man it
was mad cool i'm not gonna lie but i
gotta find it
all right so we took a little bit of a
damage
i don't know what those are
okay so those are those jump spring
things
let's just move a light along
yeah here it is
pretty sure this is it
that's what i'm saying man
i just i just don't get it i really
don't who's going to be on the ray team
addict for the destiny ray team
got myself
gaming addicts
i don't know who's going to uh
laura cognito is obviously going to be
there uh we got some people uh from the
clan like dj orris he's probably going
to be there
but besides that i don't know if we have
an entire
uh halo diddy my friend halo diddy's
gonna be there
oh
come on come at me again
are you throwing daggers at me
oh i like that speed man
that's speed sinister said he'll be
there so he's going to be there
yeah the graphics aren't the greatest
that is definitely true
like no i'm not gonna argue with that
oh
come on
oh i like that oh that feels nice
that didn't feel nice i got too into the
kill and got myself card
so that that's a boss that riding that's
pretty cool that they're just boss is
just
just just walking around
you know i did notice this loading
screen's a little too long for my taste
can you get your like souls and stuff
back in this
is it similar on that
oh
come on
let's go let's go let's go
oh
oh
i like this man i like
all right so that does take some of your
your stuff
did he just crawl on something and he's
throwing fireballs at me
yeah how'd that go for you
let's just go back and re do it so i can
get that all that flat stuff back
all right there we go
yeah you can re-collect clues like so
that awesome awesome
come on let's go
let's go you and me
whoa
all right
[Music]
all right
all right i get you
could have been better could have been
worse
i gotta like time those abilities like
he's they're a little bit speedy they
come at you pretty fast
so let's do this again
all right all right all right we got to
get these creature movements down man
come on
oh
[Music]
wow man
no it's it's not sacro it's not sacro
i'm not used to this
yeah the fast pace is pretty good i just
got to get used to
to this this ability with uh
what what's going on are you going to
complete the game fire i don't know
firebird
like here like when it comes to the
souls games like i love these type of
games but i will drop them pretty fast
unfortunately
come on move
come on
there we go so
gotta really stick to to the abilities
okay
all right we good there
oh i remember that
move
[Music]
of course you missed them all
what are you missing
wow
[Music]
i just like this plays a lot more like
the demon souls franchise and it's not
that i'm not i don't like those games
because i do but like i'm so used to
sacro like the bloodborne franchise and
it's a lot more quick pace
what's up smooth
wow
and look how long it takes to get that
hill
[Music]
but the one thing i had to remember is
like there is
there is like a stun animation on people
when i do that ability
[Music]
let's get you up here
i don't like how slow i am
i felt like i could be a lot faster than
that
man you right back in here you really
don't quit do you man
it's like i said man you could give your
opinion but you don't got to be all
extra about this stuff
like
wow
where did these people come from
oh my god
yeah let's get him up out of there metal
i gave him a chance
and he came in here still with that um
i just
what's funny is they act like they're
winning because we acknowledge that
they're being foolishness in the chat
which we have to we have to acknowledge
you like we can't let you just run wild
in the chat
we have to acknowledge you but at the
end of the day
all you're doing
is just wasting your energy
so i don't understand why people do that
stuff you're just wasting your energy
like because when you get blocked you
can't talk anymore so literally that
that isn't even
you you've won nothing
so
[Music]
that's just a part that just irritates
me man it's just like people really
live
to upset other people and like look i i
troll just as much as the next guy i do
and you guys know i do
but i won't go out of my way to troll
people it's just it's just it's it's too
much energy
i can't see this dude i know there's
another dude there okay
man you are just a speedy little bastard
taking me a little bit time to get used
to it when's the next awesome next
tuesday man next
i need to remember he does that
it's tuesday look look look look dawn
looked on let me look
don listen to me man i know i should
have did a show
tuesday i know i should have
but i was playing destiny the witch
queen and i promised myself unless
there's anything big news going on
if there's a game that's dropping that
i've been anticipating
i wouldn't pick
the attic show over that game
and there wasn't really any huge news
let's be real here ain't nobody ain't
nothing going down in the middle of
february
so you know it kind of took a break man
took a break
yeah i was slacking no i definitely
slack him man he's definitely slacking
well i was
come on man i know you want to come over
here
oh my god
what's up live supremacy
starting to get used to his movements a
little bit
[Music]
oh you hit me
what happened
where did he come from
you guys just going to keep throwing the
fireballs over and over again
i mean we could stay here all day
that went well for them
try to uh i think i got to get my
strength up to be of a robot
got to get my strength up
all right so strength
affects your posterity
okay
let's just get my strength up a little
bit because i do want to be a little bit
more agile
and now i can dodge these people because
i'm trying to fight that boss i'm pretty
sure that opens up the door yeah
travel through the mist
see what happens now man i remember this
dude
oh oh
i said if i remember correctly starts
throwing them
oh
oh
get him
speedy bit oh
oh
oh
oh
battle hammer
i'm never going to use that
ever
and no realm do i ever use the battle
hammer
yeah let's return to uh
i like i really enjoy
the
that like special ability that the
samurai have where like you sheed the
sword i think it's really versatile
like they got one for close range they
got one that gives a good variety sweep
i think that's going to be really
helpful in the future what's up meds
what's going on meds
oh i like that that's a nice little look
i wonder how that doesn't hurt me but
falling down that hurts me oh it's a
bear
sorry for waking you up i'll leave you
alone
it's more bears dragonfly looking things
yeah we're gonna
we're gonna act like we never saw none
of that we're gonna move right past all
of that
chillin man yeah it's it's good so far
correctly that's the thing that like
killed me
we don't want to go that way
that looks like a mistake we don't want
to go that way yeah so far it's pretty
good man so far it's pretty good
flame you want to do me a solid flame or
meds um ahmad's got to do it
because uh you know we can't some of you
you know we we gotta we gotta maintain
before we put
people with that mod status because uh
some of you be extra and that's fine
and i lowkey think some of you would
abuse the hell out of that mod feature
on certain people can you imagine if
more people could had mod status chris
wrote
i almost said chris righteous i mean
chris christopher hart
would be
[Music]
so many people would would just abuse
the hell out of their part power
if they if they had abilities with chris
righteousness
you guys know i'm right too maybe not
you
but chris wright you said not chris
righteous man i don't know why i was
always confused about it's not that i
confused them always want to like call
christopher heart chris righteous
but i can't imagine
what would happen
he'd be getting timed out every five
minutes he has like a a crazy statement
in the chat i can see you guys right now
man just timing them out over and over
again just timing them out over and over
again obviously we would never let that
happen
because we do got to keep it relatively
down the middle you guys know most of us
you guys know
most of us
play on the xbox brand more than
anything else but we do try to keep it
keep it civil we do try to keep it civil
what's going on over here
they walling right now man they're
coming at me with everything they got
is he still coming at me no i guess he's
got a diameter that he's got to maintain
he can't go past it
all right all right so on on to the
favor flame on to the favor before i got
in that giant
round table thing discussion about
people abusing the mod privilege
all right all right flame go to the iron
lords podcast twitch channel and copy
that url at the top and spam that in the
chat a couple times not too much
maybe five or six times
and i'll be streaming this tomorrow on
the iop twitch channel at 5 p.m
5 p.m guys
5 pm
only the twitch channel because like i
told you man got to keep it got to keep
it
somewhat
balanced
this is how it's gonna go okay i'm gonna
put the concealer down for a second
that's how it's gonna go
we're going to play
the rest of this today probably get off
from 9 9 30.
probably try to play a little bit more i
do want to play more but got the girl in
the other room can't really be having
her sit there man we got to keep it
level
can't go single man can't get dumped for
some elden ring you guys
guys say that can't get dumped for some
elden ring so what we gonna do is we
will play this for about another 30
minutes to an hour maybe a little longer
depending what's going on then we're
going to go in there
and i'm going to
put the chat of the iron lords podcast
twitch in the description or in the in
the comments section or in the chat damn
it the chat
and you guys go there man if you guys
really enjoyed the stream you know go go
to the twitch channel man like it on the
twitch channel
i i'm trying to be a little bit better
with the twitch channel trying to be a
little bit more interactive over there
because you guys know
that
they say all the time don't put all
your eggs in one basket and we're trying
to be a little bit better on that man
because we have a lot of eggs in the in
the in the youtube community let's be
real here we're trying to be a little
bit more balanced
on having
more eggs and everywhere so that's
that's what we're going off here
all right so that's all i'm gonna spam
that's all i'm doing
when you playing retro games again
i don't know man i don't know
so i do like that we like the mind
because that's where the the the samurai
abilities are coming from but i don't
know if we want to really invest into
that so i'm going to put one in health
because more health is always good more
health is always good
dexterity
i don't remember exactly dexterity
all
um
all right chat chat
listen to me chat listen to me
what is a good
thing to invest into
now endurance
all right so it's probably i probably
need to do endurance
let's do endurances get this up just a
little bit
what am i beating those retro games
again
i don't know
look man
that's right like they kind of they
didn't mentally defeat me but man i was
a little frustrated with those
those games man
there's no denying that i was a little
frustrated
ow
all right all right all right me and you
me and you
how'd that go for you
miss addict in the streams man first off
i'm not married on so so don't don't put
that on me man don't put that on me
what's up
and i don't think she would appreciate
being in the streams she's a little shy
a little shy when it comes to stuff like
that
let's get rid of him
oh it took a lot of endurance right
there
dudes with the spears not easy to take
out
just
gradually go over them
oh you're not dead
now you are
one would think a backstab will kill
these people
all right so we don't want to deal with
all those because it looks like right
there we have to deal with two three
four and a dog
i don't want that smoke i don't think
i'm ready for that smoke
so we're gonna move back we're gonna
move back a little bit
i got the elden ring for is it like look
obviously i haven't beat elton ring is
the elden ring legit ring or is that
like
a like just something they call the
aldrin ring but it's like a giant stone
or something i don't know i don't know
if people know that maybe actually don't
say that don't say that because it's
like a kind of a spoiler so keep that to
yourself in the chat
flask add charge to flask
i love how they say you don't have one
the storm gates
no the storm
oh
what is this thing
hold up
is he gonna chase me forever
he's got a giant sword
man
there is a dude
i don't know how i feel about this
hold up
ah
hold up
all right all right all right
chat should i try to fight the big dude
get out of my way i'm trying to talk to
the chat if i want to fight the big dude
all right all right all right all right
all right should i fight the big giant
dude right there is trying to run past
put a one in the chat if i should try to
fight him and die or two in the chat
if i should
curious what you guys feel like i should
do because i feel like he's gonna kill
me
but if you guys feel like i have the
correct requirements to fight this dude
i'll fight him
i'll fight him
no lucius is like don't do that run go
the other way
ow
he got no neck fight
he got no neck
he got no neck all right we doing it we
do it let's try
maybe i should i can't really fight i
don't hold up
he's up there
jump off fam
i need you to come down here away from
your little archers
and i need you to stop doing that
there you go
come down here beast titan from attack
on titan let's go i probably gonna lose
but we gonna do this
yo
you don't do no damage to him at all
you guys trying to get me killed
ah
you don't have to keep stomping on me
man we can be friends
we can be friends
i promise you we could be friends
you're pulling out a sword
how'd that go for you tonight
all right let's go let's go let's go you
go what are you gonna do what are you
gonna
do i'm behind you idiot
let's go
come on man
i know you got better than that
there you go there you go buddy
buddy
what happened what happened you had like
like 50 feet on me man
what happened
you know what they say the bigger they
are the harder they fall
had like 50 feet on me guys
kind of nonsense was that
i feel a little bit that's what i'm
looking for
i feel like that could have went better
for him just a little bit
i feel like that could have went better
for him
i don't know
we're gonna we're gonna
raise the endurance again
but
the reason we're going to raise the
endurance is because i want
to make sure that i can roll better
see look at that that feels pretty good
right there
[Music]
does he spawn back oh he spawns back we
could beat this dude again
i don't he might beat us this time
no
come on come down here
round two fight
let's go
ow
think we could do it one more time man i
think we could do it again
are you ever gonna come down here
man you taking your time
i want to fight this dude now if he had
a cup he would have won probably
would have ate my soul or drunk my soul
or whatever there you go buddy
there you go
there you go
oh
can you catch me
can you catch me buddy
let's do that again
ow all right let's not do that let's
fight him legitly
you guys don't have man we go between
the legs
he over commits we punish him
we don't get hit by that because that's
bad for us go but
between the legs over commits punish him
we eat
because we don't want to die from like
one hit
now he pulls out the sword because he's
a beast with the sword
ah
that's unnecessary dude you got a sword
i got a sword you should want to fight
on equal terms
over commit
he's not the smartest dude in the world
it's fine over commit punish it
over commit punish him
oh he couldn't he would have jamed my
ass man oh
oh chopped his head's off man
got him got him up out of there
got him up out of there you guys know
how things are you know how imma do
things
and then this dude think he got
something going he got nothing
oh
love the samurai man love the samurai
i like this move i'm not gonna lie
i'm fanboying over this move
[Music]
all right so now
all right so now let's go ahead and
let's get this let's get your health up
one more time
we're not gonna fight him this time
because uh as you can see
it's kind of useless for us to continue
wasting time doing that
we're gonna go past him
he's kind of a chump he's got size of
nothing else that's always got going for
him
just the size
these two got nothing either
[Music]
oh you can [ __ ]
yeah we ain't doing that we running
we we we don't believe in like eight on
ones and and stuff like that
if we can't do fair fights we run i
don't know what a golden seat is but
we're gonna go with them and we're gonna
go with it
just dogs
oh some dogs we ain't fighting dogs
either
we passing everybody
what is that
adding skills what the if you can use
ashes to grant your immune seals
you can use it
okay
i don't know
we'll worry about that here in a second
we're not trying to get hit by
whatever that is
yeah stop that
you should know better boy
you should know better
all right this is all i remember when it
come to like the um
the whatever that thing was called
oh god
come on let's go
you guys can do better
is this all you guys got
oh why you running
why are you running
oh that dude there looks a little bit
deadly i ain't gonna lie that one right
there
i don't know if i want to fight him
a little bit concerned fighting him he
he said he ain't even looking at me he
just turned around
i remember there's a boss up here that
i'm probably gonna lose
a couple times
it's good enough to level up once and
we're gonna go fight him
now i probably won't beat this dude on
my first try
oh come on
oh
you guys know how it is
everything i do
all right so we got like 700 a little
bit
huh
can you break this
apparently not
i gotta believe
hey buddy
ow
that's unnecessary
right here man right here you two versus
me who gonna win them two or me
let's go let's go let's go
oh
oh
oh this dude looks like he
he got his stuff together
come on
oh he got his stuff together
he got his stuff together
oh
that seemed like it hurt a little bit
but he did he did a little bit of damage
to me i'll give him that
what's this over here
appreciate how you guys came up in here
man
you know
i need to to
together get over
here here's the twitch channel like i
told you guys
that twitch channel man if you want to
see me play more of this i'll be playing
this tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern on the
iron lures podcast twitch channel
so definitely go in there and
and follow that account get ready for
that stream because this it's like i
said it's how we're going to do it let's
pull back for the newer man pull back
for the new ones
this stream's going to be on the on the
youtube channel we're going to stream
one time on brand new games to the
youtube channel show you guys how we
like the first impressions you guys know
how it is when it comes to the destiny 2
raid
we'll be doing that on both
but we're going to be streaming the
elden ring on the on the twitch channel
from tomorrow going forward when it
comes to this so keep that in mind guys
go over there follow that twitch channel
because that's where we'll be playing
and my neck hurts
oh there's a lot of them over there oh
let's eat
let's bug them a little bit let's bug
them a little bit we got a horse let's
use it
what's up guys
can i hit one of you
all right all right all right let's do
this get oh
okay okay okay okay i got you i got you
i got you guys doing are you bringing it
except for this dude here
he did
ow
come on let's go let's go oh
really stood no chance
yeah i get it man red dead i get it the
massive log
it it's
it's it's a thing man like we have a lot
of games that we just sit here and we
waste money on and i get it if you don't
want to justify going out and spending
money on this when you ain't played any
of that so i definitely understand that
and i respect that man i respect it
i respect it
all right all right so do we have enough
to level up and if we love what should
we level up
we gonna level one time before we go
fight we need a little bit just a little
bit
[Music]
more come on
come on
come on
m
got your stuff together bye boy
what is luck level up hair okay okay
okay normally i will backstab this dude
but he gave me a good fight last time so
i feel like i owe him to
come on man i owe him a good fight
i guess i guess i guess that was a fluke
man i guess that was a fluke he ain't
really about that life i got him he
ain't really about that life
what is this oh it's a message
from the online
trolling community got a bunch of metal
heads or whatever that dude's name was
giving me advice there so we don't want
to really
listen to the online community too too
much
level up look let me see what luck does
okay look is that arcane is that what
luck is
i'm streaming
well probably not thank you though um
should i level up mind
i kind of feel like i should level up
strength
all right hold up hold up
let me look here real quick
like okay
i remember in the older
dark souls games
it was like if you load up dexterity and
shrink they leveled up two different
things
so attribute required to advance or okay
so let's
what is dexterity
okay so
all right all right
let's level up let's just level up mind
i do feel like we'll need that i feel
like we'll need that
all right so chad we we about to lose
here okay i'm prepared to lose this
fight
foul tarnished
in search of the elderly
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
here we go guys sorry my brother came in
i had to see what he wanted
all right so this dude's about to beat
me we all know this
but i'm trying to give you guys
one
two
all right so i remember a little bit
fighting him in the beta
[Music]
i thought he was about to fall off the
map for a second
come on
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
ow
doing too much there
mel margaret the fall omen whatever your
name is
oh
come on come on let's go
come on
oh he's got a hammer
oh man
it's a good try man it's a good try
we're gonna fight we're gonna try this
dude again though we're gonna try this
dude again i feel like
i feel rejuvenated i feel like i can
beat him i don't know
the hammer kind of caught me off guard a
little bit the hammer kind of caught me
off guard a little bit i ain't gonna lie
to you guys the hammer kind of caught me
off guard a little bit but i felt like i
was doing the timing of the fights right
it felt like i was doing that correct
i feel like i can beat him i really do
feel like i can beat him if i really
come on
come on
gotta do better at dodging man
all right
[Music]
i gotta run like full blown run i can't
do that anymore
oh
like i
i wonder how that
there's got to be a better way if i full
blown run i feel like his that attack
won't hit me as much
all right let's try this again let's go
grab this
he seems to
try to do that a lot but it's okay
dodge that hit him with this get him one
time with that run back a little bit
seems like you always want to be in
front of them you don't want to be
behind it too much
i gotta dodge those better
that's what's killing me is those
[Music]
all right here we go here we go here we
go
is he ever going to come at me
i'm right here man come on
let's go
one
two
[Music]
[Music]
come on let's go
one two
one
two
i might stop doing that too because i
think that might be one of my issues
you being a little extra man i love it
[Music]
all right so
oh
[Music]
all right man all right man let's go
let's go
come on omen
make a move
[Music]
not that move you don't have to get the
hammer out
oh my god
you didn't have to get the hammer out
man you was doing just fine without that
big hammer
is there a way to parry tax i don't
believe in parrying attacks don't be
real with you flying you know why i
don't believe parent attacks because
those perry systems are always so
inconsistent with these type of games
one game they'll work fine the next game
they don't work fine so you know what i
believe in flame i don't believe in
pairing i believe in just dodging the
attack that's what i believe in
come on omen
come on omen
you got this omen
i i mean
come on omen
oh
[Music]
it's time to run time to run time to run
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing omen pull out your
hammer
this dude don't respect me enough you
don't think that i deserve the hammer
there you go omen
i deserve that hammer
the hammer
deserves to be used on me
pause
nah
oh
[Music]
come on come on
[Music]
you don't have to get so close with the
hammer
oh my god people were taking the hammer
thing a little too fast man
look man just because i was asking for
the hammer don't mean i was asking for
some some sexually way you guys are
perverted man like i can ask for a
hammer about some sexual stuff coming in
the chat man
come on come on
look i felt away he didn't feel like i
that i was respected enough to for him
to use a hammer on me i apologize for
that actually no i don't
that was disrespectful he didn't want to
use the hammer on me
and notice that it don't work out well
for man
one
two
ow that's the first time that's ever hit
me
so far it's definitely good man so far
it's definitely good
come on omen
i believe in you
you were supposed to be the chosen one
omen
you're supposed to bring the the balance
to the force holmen
the hammer gods
they're they're scared of you man
you're supposed to be there for us old
man
[Music]
i believed in you omen
it's that quick one that would get you
man that quick one
thor would be proud of you omen
i actually think thor would have came at
me with that hammer by now i'ma just be
real with you
thor don't discriminate he pulls that
hammer out first
[Music]
oh
come on omen don't gotta be so odd
we friends here we friends
[Music]
won't you pull that hammer out oh
[Music]
you knew
that was that was messed up element
you knew what you was doing there open
[Music]
that was wrong
you knew what she was doing there omen
come on alvin
i'm making it so easy for you omen
[Music]
come on omen
come on omen
let's go omen
i believe in you man
i believe in your omen
i believe in you you can do this omen
you versus me old man my money's on you
come on old man you almost got this i
get hit one more time it's a wrap oh man
one more time oh man that's all it's
gonna take
and then you got me omen
okay maybe two more hits omen you had me
two more times
[Music]
two more times old man you got it one
more time open one more time
i believe in you the force is on your
side
you got me old man i can't move
come on olmen
i'm barely hanging on oh man where you
doing
ah man
[Music]
he had he had enough man he could have
got me he could easily have gotten me
out of there
it took him a minute it took him a
minute
it took me a minute man i'm gonna
probably i'm gonna fight him one more
time one more good sign
but then i gotta go man i got
i can't neglect the girlfriend man i
gotta go after that
can i summon something
oh let's let's summon a crow a
cooperator hold up let's go
see normally i don't summon stuff like
this but here's how i'm putting that i
want to be entertaining let's see how
oman fights with a mage and a and a
samurai let's see how this goes
yeah let's go let's go
look he ain't even trying to dodge he's
just getting old
oh man no
that's my buddy omen
who you gonna fight omen me or him who
you gonna fight omen me or him
you got this omen
it's just two of us
you just gotta hit us like 80 times
hey ole miss i'm over here omen
[Music]
keep hitting a moment
keep hitting the moment
you got this omen
you got this open
you can beat a moment
you just turned off the xbox what
that's that's the stream man my
girlfriend turned off the xbox man it's
it's cool it's cool
uh i appreciate everyone coming by man i
didn't want to beat him that way anyway
but i you guys have a good day man it
was a good stream we'll come back
tomorrow on twitch